bonsoir je vais jany merci d'être avec
nous on le voit des restrictions tout de
même imposé aux belges pendant les fêtes
c'était nécessaire selon vous oui
c'était nécessaire à cause
essentiellement du de la fatigue du
personnel soignant et de la pression que
le gouvernement ne veut plus mettre sur
les hôpitaux et donc c'était là la seule
chose à faire pour ne pas vivre une
troisième vague ou alors une deuxième
vague d'un peu prolongée parce qu'on va
en belgique actuellement qu'on est en
train de de sortir de cette deuxième
vague
voilà le nombre de patients hospitalisés
en soin intensif est pourtant passé sous
la barre des 600 enfin c'est déjà trop
mais en tout cas voilà ça a tendance à
baisser pour la première fois en près de
deux mois on observe en revanche une
hausse des décontaminations c'est
justement vous venez de dire à
destination des hôpitaux cette mesure il
faut à tout prix baisser
ces hospitalisations et vider les
hôpitaux qui craquent en belgique
donc bien sûr que c'est des mesures de
prudence je pensais donc on va accepter
ces mesures-là ce soutien ces mesures de
prudence mais j'ai toujours dit je pense
qu'il faut apprendre aussi à vivre avec
le corps n'a donc le métier des hôpitaux
c'est de soigner et donc avoir 2010
occuper enfin on a nous avons 2000 lits
de soins intensifs
donc c'est quand même leur fonction de
d'être occupés par des patients qui sont
malades
ce qu'il faut c'est que qu'on ne dépasse
pas 7 bar c'est vrai qu'au sommet de la
delà de la deuxième vague
nous avions sept mille lits hospitaliers
occupés dont un peu plus que 1000 aux
soins intensifs mais il faut savoir
qu'il y a trente cinq mille lits
hospitaliers aiguë en belgique
donc vous voyez quand même bien que on a
une petite saturation du nombre de lits
on a déjà bloqué le pays
donc là la prudence s'imposait donc le
facteur limitant n'est pas le nombre de
lits mais c'est
la disponibilité du personnel soignant
compétents et qui peut assurer ses soins
là et donc ça c'est vraiment des
personnes qui sont un peu plus rare que
les autres et c'est pour ça que il
fallait un peu les préserver d'autant
plus qu'on ne savait pas vraiment que la
deuxième vague allait arriver si vite et
donc c'est une mesure de prudence qui
est qui qui est acceptable
au vu de la situation actuelle et qu'il
faut continuer pour pour vraiment
espérer ne pas avoir de troisième vague
avant l'arrivée du vaste dont évidemment
que la belgique est en quelque sorte
traumatisés comme leçon de nombreux pays
mais il n'empêche c'est l'un des pays
qui a connu le plus de morts
proportionnellement à sa population
aujourd'hui avec quelques mois de recul
est ce que on s'explique
les raisons de ce mauvais bilan si j'ose
dire bah je pense que je l' ai déjà dit
ce n'est pas un mauvais bilan il faudra
tirer le vrai bilan dans un an ou deux
la mortalité la plus importante pas avec
ceux coronavirus et celle des personnes
très âgées 81 90 ans
et donc c'est vrai qu'on peut décéder
d'une fracture ou d'une chute ou d'un
autre problème de santé et être porteur
du virus à ce moment là donc ce qu'il
faudra faire s'est comparé la mortalité
globale dans le pays
d'une année à l'autre avec la mentalité
qu'on a qu'on a pu observer pendant sept
années de conduite pour pouvoir dire
qu'un pays a fait mieux qu'un autre mais
donc aujourd'hui ce n'est pas un critère
très précis qui est celui du nombre de
morts qu'on peut attribuer
enfin au courant d'un virus alors une
lueur d'espoir
ce vaccin dont tout le monde parle
notamment aujourd'hui l instant
d'ailleurs l'allemagne prévoit de
commencer sa campagne de vaccination le
27 décembre
c'est ce qu'annonce le ministre de la
santé alors celui-là vandal
y'en avait l'air de dire que tous les
pays européens seraient logés à la même
enseigne
ça pourrait être la même chose pour vous
les belges le 27 décembre pourquoi pas
c'est quelque chose que vous accueillez
avec optimisme prudent ce la vaccination
l'accueil avec ou de joie il y à un
commissaire qui a été nommée par le
gouvernement pour s'occuper du plan de
d'organisation de la vaccination
nous avons reçu déjà quelques
informations pour la vaccination en
trois étapes la première étape étant
bien sûr le personnel
enfin le personnel soignant mais aussi
donc l'ailé les patients les plus
fragiles
et puis donc les étapes suivantes pour
les le personnel à l'extérieur des
hôpitaux et dans d'autres catégories de
patients et enfin le restant de la
population
le vaccin n'est pas obligatoire mais il
est conseillé et je pense que dans le
milieu des soignants en tout cas dans le
milieu où je vis beaucoup de personnes
vont se faire vacciner pour être
rassurés sur l'avenir
alors j'aimerais juste rappeler un point
fondamental qui est que le fait que le
coran la virus
à part la mortalité qui est quand même
importante dans certaines catégories et
d'âge est bien et ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas le seul problème donc je pense que
les gens à se faire vacciner pour les
autres soucis de morbidité qu'il cause
notamment à part les problèmes
pulmonaires mais aussi des problèmes ne
fut-ce que de perte de goût et l'odorat
certaines personnes ont ça depuis le
mois de mars est donc on est quand même
à plusieurs moyennes n'ont toujours pas
récupéré
je pense que le vaccin il est utile pas
seulement pour éviter le décès mais pour
éviter les conséquences qui sont parfois
très lourdes au niveau de la vie
quotidienne et qui sont causés par ce
virus des séquelles importantes et
encore un navire russe merci gilbert bun
rany d'avoir été avec nous en direct
donc de belgique merci à vous